this is the graph paper we usually draw
our graphs on
every unit horizontally as well as
vertically is one centimeter long
every centimeter is divided into 10
millimeters by these thin lines
let's try to draw a graph of the example
we had seen previously
zen used to receive a weekly allowance
of 100 rupees per week
to convince his dad to increase his
monthly allowance he presented the
following data to his dad
these are the weekly allowances of five
kids in his neighborhood
to represent this diagrammatically
zen plans to draw vertical bars for
weekly allowances but the important
question that pops up in his head is
what scale should he choose on the
y-axis
there are a couple of things that affect
the scale
first the range of the data
by range i mean the difference between
the greatest and the smallest value
and second the number of grid lines
let us find out the range first
the largest value in this set is 300
which is carly's weekly allowance
and the smallest value is 100 which is
zen's allowance
the range will be 300 minus 100.
the largest value minus the smallest
value
it equals 200
let's say we take one centimeter equal
to 50 rupees on the y-axis as the scale
it means we will need four centimeters
to cover this range
assuming we start the y-axis at 0 we
also have to count for the range between
0 and 100
that will be an additional 2 centimeters
it means we will need around 6 grid
lines to cover this range of data
remember the scale you have to choose
should need a maximum of 8 grid lines
a graph paper generally has around 10
grid lines
anything more than that will not fit
into the graph paper
now that we have chosen the scale we
draw the x and the y-axis
we have the name of the kids on the
x-axis
and the weekly allowances of each of the
kids on the y-axis
we have asha ben carly dave ellen and
zen on the x axis
as we have chosen a scale of 50 rupees
per centimeter on the y-axis
we mark 50 100 150 and so on up to 300.
this range as we can see has covered all
the data points and it also fits into a
graph perfectly
asha gets a weekly allowance of 150
rupees
it means we need to draw a bar up to
this height
so we draw a bar like this
this bar represents asha's weekly
allowance
to represent ben's weekly allowance we
draw a bar up to 200
like this
and we continue to draw bars for other
data points as well
and then zen tells his dad that
everybody's weekly allowance is more
than what he's given every week look at
the scale we have chosen
many times students ask if this is the
only possible scale
well the answer to that is not
necessarily
it was just an estimation
we could also have chosen one centimeter
as 45 rupees
it would still have covered around 7 to
8 grid lines which fits perfectly into
this graph paper
but the y-axis points would have been 45
135 and would not look very nice
it would also have become a bit
difficult to plot these values as they
are not multiples of 45
but if the question is is this the best
possible scale we could have chosen
the answer to that i would say is yes
it is the best possible scale